even as we speak
time speeds swiftly away
begin
be bold
and venture to be wise
rule your mind
or it will rule you
whatever advice you give
be brief
wisdom is not wisdom when it is derived
from books alone
he who has begun something is already
halfway done
dare to be wise
begin
big promises reduce trust
a new vessel smells for a long time of
what it was filled with for the first
time
he who feared that he would not succeed
sat still
he who is greedy
is always in want
faults are soon copied
you cross the whole world in search of
happiness
and it is always there at arm's length
from any person
make money
money by fair means if you can
if not
make them by any means
once a word has been allowed to escape
it cannot be recalled
anger is a brief madness
what you have not published you can
destroy
the word once set forth
can never be recalled
who has self-confidence will lead the
rest
all that is hidden now will once be
revealed by time
subdue your passion
or it will subdue you
without love and laughter there is no
joy
live amid love and laughter
he who postpones the hour of living
rightly is like the rustic who waits for
the river to run out before he crosses
if you don't run while you're healthy
you'll have to run when you're sick
manage your mood because if it does not
obey
then it commands
[Music]
in love there are two evils
war and peace
a shoe that is too large is apt to trip
one
and when too small to pinch the feet so
it is with those whose fortune does not
suit them
humor is often stronger and more
effective
than sharpness and cutting naughty
issues
trying to be brief
you become incomprehensible
a force devoid of reason perishes by
itself
he will always be a slave who does not
know how to live upon a little
if any man cannot feel the power of god
when he looks upon the stars
then i doubt whether he is capable of
any feeling at all
what are you laughing at
a story is told about you with a changed
name
the aim of the poet is to inform or
delight
or to combine together
in what he says both pleasure and
applicability to life
life grants nothing to us mortals
without hard work
a hypocrite can be spotted
by three signs
when he tells
he lies
when he promises
he violates
when he is trusted
he betrays
what do people have the most
hope
because even those who have nothing else
have it
people will never trust a person without
a share of doubt
you can only tell the one who trusts you
[Music]
do not shy away from business
but do not fuss too much
capture your reader let him not depart
from dull beginnings that refuse to
start
a person's weakness is shown in his
inability to refuse
fear of making a mistake involves
another
beauty dies from wine
youth is reduced by wine
if you wish people to weep
you must weep first
love not what you want to love
and what you can
what you have
mingle a little folly with your wisdom
a little nonsense now and then
is pleasant
we are just statistics
born to consume resources
it would be less madness to carry
firewood into the forest
you may drive out nature with a
pitchfork
yet she still will hurry back
mix a little foolishness with your
serious plans
it is lovely to be silly at the right
moment
virtue dear friend needs no defense
the surest guard is innocent
none knew till guild created fear
what darts or poisoned arrows were
fool makes a fortune of those it favors
too much
you procure the noblest building
materials when only a pick and a spade
are needed and you build a house 500
feet long and 100 feet wide
for getting a dwelling six feet
remember when life's path is steep to
keep your mind even
adversity has the effect of eliciting
talents which
in prosperous circumstances
would have lain dormant
the man who mingles the useful with the
sweet carries the day by charming his
reader
and at the same time
instructing him
what we read with pleasure we read again
with pleasure
people don't like when you repeat it
twice
count your birthdays with gratitude
in peace
as a wise man
he should make suitable preparation for
war
how slight and insignificant is the
thing which casts down or restores a
mind greedy for praise
clogged with yesterday's excess
the body drags the mind down with it
leave off asking what tomorrow will
bring and whatever day's fortune will
give
count them as profit
think to yourself that every day is your
last
the hour to which you do not look
forward
will come as a welcome surprise
pale death with impartial tread beats at
the poor man's cottage door
and at the palaces of kings
if there is nothing pleasant without
love and fun
live in love and fun
in a miserable situation
don't forget to defend the stability of
the soul
it is reason and wisdom which take away
cares
not places affording wide views over the
sea
this is a fault common to singers that
among their friends they were never
inclined to sing when they were asked
unasked
they never desist
either stick to tradition or see that
your inventions are consistent
it is courage
courage
courage
that raises the blood of life to crimson
splendor
live bravely and present a brave front
to adversity
live as brave men
and if fortune is adverse
front its blows with brave hearts
wisdom
is the principle and source of beautiful
writing
these quotes from horus show what a man
of dry wit he was and we can also see
that he had a great sense of humor even
though poetry wasn't his life ambition
he gave all of us a lot of amazing
quotes
thanks for watching